This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. It happens in an instant. You move too fast and you feel a wrench in your back. That first sharp pain is followed by a persistent ache, bothersome enough to send you to the doctor. A scan reveals a problem. A specialist recommends surgery. You go under the knife, trusting that once the damaged tissue is repaired,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这一切发生在电光石火之间。你动作太快，突然感觉后背一阵剧痛。那阵剧烈刺痛之后，是挥之不去的酸痛，足以让你去看医生。扫描发现了一个问题。专家建议做手术。你上了手术台，坚信一旦受损组织修复，
the pain will disappear. The story makes intuitive sense. diagnose the problem, fix the bone or ligament or tendon that is not working properly, and you'll make the pain go away. But for many of us, that's not how pain unfolds. Aks persist even when scans look normal, or they vanish without any medical intervention. Treatments that promise relief fail to deliver.
疼痛就会消失。这个故事在直觉上完全说得通：诊断出问题，修复运作不正常的骨骼、韧带或肌腱，疼痛自然就会消失。但对我们许多人来说，疼痛的发展并非如此。即使扫描结果正常，疼痛依然存在；或者没有任何医疗干预，疼痛却自行消失了。承诺带来缓解的治疗却毫无效果。
We also notice something puzzling. The pain we feel changes with other things happening in our lives. When we're feeling calm or absorbed in the life, or absorbed in something else, the pain subsides. When we feel isolated or sad, the pain gets worse. Today on the show, and in a companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we examine why our culture gets so many things wrong when it comes to understanding the true nature of pain.
我们还注意到一个令人费解的现象。我们感受到的疼痛会随着生活中发生的其他事情而改变。当我们感到平静、沉浸在生活中，或是全神贯注于别的事情时，疼痛就会减轻。当我们感到孤立或悲伤时，疼痛就会加剧。今天的节目，以及《隐藏的大脑 Plus》中的配套单集，将探讨为什么我们的文化在理解疼痛的本质时会产生如此多的误解。
What's really happening when we experience pain and how to address it? This week, on Hidden Brain. Pain feels like a simple message from the body. If your elbow hurts, they must be able to be. something wrong with your elbow. If your back is painfully stiff, you need some work done on your back. The brain in this model is an observer. It registers signals of pain sent in by nerves from the far reaches of the body. But is that really all there is to it? At the University of California, San Francisco, psychologist Rachel Zoffner studies the nature of pain. She has found that our
当我们经历疼痛时，究竟发生了什么？又该如何应对？本周，尽在《隐藏的大脑》。疼痛感觉像是来自身体的简单信息。如果你的肘部疼痛，肘部肯定出了问题。如果你的背部痛得僵硬，你的背部就需要接受治疗。在这种模式下，大脑是一个旁观者。它记录着来自身体远端神经发送的疼痛信号。但事实真的仅此而已吗？在加利福尼亚大学旧金山分校，心理学家雷切尔·佐夫尼斯（Rachel Zoffness）专门研究疼痛的本质。她发现，我们的
minds play a much larger role in our experience of pain than many of us realize, and the also play a much larger role in how we need to deal with pain. Rachel Zoffness, welcome to Hidden Brain. One of my favorite ever podcasts. I'm so honored to be here. Rachel, as you began your own research training, you were taught a one-dimensional biomedical model of pain. Can you describe that model for me? Absolutely. The biomedical model is an antiquated way of looking at disease and pain that focuses primarily if not exclusively on anatomy and physiology and bones and body parts.
心灵在我们对疼痛的体验中扮演着比许多人意识到的要重要得多的角色，而且在我们需要如何应对疼痛方面，心灵同样扮演着至关重要的角色。雷切尔·佐夫尼斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。这是我最喜欢的播客之一。我太荣幸能来到这里了。雷切尔，在你刚开始进行研究培训时，你被灌输的是一种一维的生物医学疼痛模型。你能为我描述一下那个模型吗？当然可以。生物医学模型是一种看待疾病和疼痛的陈旧方式，它主要（如果不是全部的话）聚焦于解剖学、生理学、骨骼以及身体各个部位。
And what that means in the biomedical frame of things is that when we talk about treating pain, we also talk primarily if not exclusively about biomedical solutions. And that takes the form of pills and procedures. So here's what I observe as a clinician and pain researcher. What I observe is that if you have chronic knee pain, you will be sent to 762 knee specialists, but we never talk about your brain at all. So early on in your own training, Rachel, you encountered a pair of clinical cases documented in the medical literature, which got you thinking about pain in a different way.
在生物医学框架下，这意味着当我们谈论治疗疼痛时，我们也主要（如果不是全部的话）在谈论生物医学解决方案。这通常表现为吃药和做手术。因此，作为一名临床医生和疼痛研究人员，我观察到的是：如果你有慢性的膝盖疼痛，你会被转诊给762名膝盖专家，但我们却绝口不提你的大脑。所以，雷切尔，在你的早期培训中，你遇到了医学文献中记录的一对临床病例，这让你开始以不同的方式思考疼痛。
One was about a 29-year-old construction worker who got injured. Can you set up the scene for me and describe what happened to this worker? I love these two stories, and I call them a tale of two nails because who doesn't like rhymes. So, yes, the first story, the first tale of nails, is a construction worker who was working on a job site when he jumped off a plank straight onto a seven-inch nail. And that nail drove through his boot, clear through to the other side. Oh, my God. Yes. So the pain must have just been excruciating.
其中一个案例是一名29岁的建筑工人受伤的故事。你能为我搭建一下场景，并描述一下这位工人发生了什么吗？我非常喜欢这两个故事，我称它们为“双钉记”，因为谁能拒绝押韵呢？所以，是的，第一个故事，也就是关于钉子的第一个故事，说的是一名建筑工人在工地上工作时，从一块木板上跳下来，不偏不倚地踩在了一根七英寸长的钉子上。那根钉子穿透了他的靴子，直接扎到了另一头。天哪。是的。所以当时一定痛不欲生吧。
It was excruciating. And his colleagues rushed him off to the emergency department, and he was sedated with a lot of good drugs, like fentanyl and other opioids. And when the good doctors removed his boot, they discovered that a miracle had occurred. The nail had passed between the space between his toes. There was no puncture wound. There was no blood and there was no tissue damage. Well, but why was he in such excruciating pain? It makes no sense, right?
确实痛不欲生。他的同事们把他急忙送到急诊室，医生给他注射了大量强效药物，比如芬太尼和其他阿片类药物。当好心的医生脱下他的靴子时，他们发现了一个奇迹。那根钉子竟然穿过了他脚趾之间的缝隙。没有穿刺伤口，没有流血，也没有组织损伤。等等，那他为什么会感到如此剧烈的疼痛？这根本说不通，对吧？
So here's what pain science tells us, which is so important and fascinating about the science of pain. Our brain is our body's danger detector. That's our brain's job is to save our lives. And pain is our body's warning system. It's our danger detector. danger detection system. So our brain, including this construction worker's brain, used all available information to decide whether or not to make pain and how much. And that included knowledge of his
所以，疼痛科学告诉我们的是关于疼痛科学非常重要且迷人的一点。我们的大脑是我们身体的危险探测器。我们大脑的工作就是拯救我们的生命。疼痛就是我们身体的预警系统。它是我们的危险探测器，是危险探测系统。因此，我们的大脑，包括这位建筑工人的大脑，利用所有可用的信息来决定是否制造疼痛以及制造多少疼痛。这其中包括他对
dangerous work environment. It included memories of past pain experiences, which by the way are stored in our hippocampus. It used data from his five senses, including this vision. of this giant nail sticking out of his boot, it incorporated emotions like panic, and because his brain perceived potential threat of danger, it made pain to protect him.
危险工作环境的认知，包括过去疼痛体验的记忆（顺便说一句，这些记忆储存在我们的海马体中），它利用了来自他五官的数据，包括视觉——看到这根巨大的钉子从他的靴子里戳出来。它还融合了恐慌等情绪，由于他的大脑感知到了潜在的危险威胁，为了保护他，大脑便制造出了疼痛。
And I'm using those words on purpose. His brain perceived potential danger, and so it made pain to protect him. I'm also imagining that when he saw the reactions of the people around him, they must have just been horrified. to see this nail sticking out of his boot, and now he's getting feedback from other people,
我是故意使用这些词的。他的大脑感知到了潜在的危险，因此它制造了疼痛来保护他。我还能想象到，当他看到周围人的反应时，他们看到这根钉子从靴子里戳出来，肯定吓坏了，现在他又从其他人那里得到了反馈：
something terrible has happened to me. Absolutely, that is one of the other factors, the social input, the social data, from all the construction workers standing around him, and you can see this giant nail protruding from the top of his boot, like anybody who saw that would be equally as alarmed. Now, you said that this was a tale of two nails, and the other story that you tell is also,
我身上发生了可怕的事情。没错，这是另一个因素，也就是社交输入、社交数据，来自站在他周围的所有建筑工人。你可以看到这根巨大的钉子从他的靴子顶端凸出来，任何看到这一幕的人都会感到同样的惊恐。现在，你刚才说这是一个“双钉记”，你讲的另一个故事也是
about a construction worker, but he was working in Colorado? That's right. So this construction worker was on a job site in Colorado, and he was using a nail gun. And the nail gun accidentally misfired, and it ricocheted backwards and it clocked him in the jaw. But he saw a nail go shooting across the room and bury in the wall across from him. So he had like a mild toothache and a mild headache, but he continued on with work and life for six days. So in this case, the nail gun goes off, but he sees the nail embed itself in the wall far away from him. And even though he has a little bit of the recoil that hits his face, he thinks he's basically okay. That's exactly right. And at the end of six days, six days of eating and sleeping
关于一个建筑工人的，但他在科罗拉多州工作？没。这位建筑工人在科罗拉多州的一个工地上工作，当时他正在使用一把射钉枪。射钉枪不小心走火了，它向后反弹，击中了他的下巴。但他看到一根钉子射过房间，埋入了他正对面的墙里。因此，他只有轻微的牙痛和轻微的头痛，但他还是继续工作和生活了六天。所以在这个案例中，射钉枪响了，但他看到钉子嵌入了他远处的墙里。尽管他的脸受到了轻微的反冲撞击，但他认为自己基本上没事。完全正确。而在经历了整整六天——经历了六天的吃喝、睡觉
and continuing on with life, he turns to his wife and says, you know, I think I'm going to get this toothache checked out. So he goes to a dentist, and the dentist does a scan of his patient's jaw, and much to both men's surprise, they discover a four-inch nail embedded in his face. Wait, I thought you said the nail was basically flying across the room and embedding itself in the wall. That's right. So nail guns, I don't use many nail guns, but nail guns can actually release more than one nail at a time. They have like a rapid release. So he saw a nail shoot across the room and somehow, not sure the physics of this, but somehow a second. nail came out of the nail gun and it went up through the bottom of his jaw and into his face.
以及继续生活之后，他转向妻子说：“你知道吗，我想去检查一下这颗牙痛。”于是他去看牙医，牙医对病人的下巴进行了扫描，结果让两人都大吃一惊的是，他们发现在他的面部嵌入了一根四英寸长的钉子。等等，我记得你刚才说钉子基本上是飞过房间并嵌入墙里的。没错。所以射钉枪——我不用很多射钉枪，但射钉枪实际上可以一次释放多枚钉子。它们有类似连发的功能。所以他看到一根钉子射过房间，不知怎么的（我不懂其中的物理原理），但不知怎么的，第二枚
And I actually spoke with the surgeon that conducted the surgery and he said, he's the luckiest guy ever. That nail was protruding into his prefrontal cortex. Now, how is it possible that someone can have such significant damage and such significant damage and such little pain because this myth, this lie that we are all sold, is that pain and damage are one and the same. When you have pain, you go looking for damage. When you have damage, you assume necessarily that you should have pain. But pain or hurt and damage or harm are not the same thing. hurt and harm are not the same. I'm really puzzled here, Rachel.
钉子从射钉枪里射了出来，穿过他下巴的底部，刺入了面部。我实际上和进行手术的外科医生交谈过，他说：“他是史上最幸运的人。那根钉子刺入了他的前额叶皮层。”现在，一个人怎么可能受到如此严重的伤害，身体遭受了这么大的创伤，却几乎感觉不到疼痛呢？因为我们所有人被灌输的这个神话、这个谎言，就是疼痛和损伤是一回事。当你感到疼痛时，你就会去寻找损伤。当你有了损伤，你自然会认为你应该感到疼痛。但疼痛（或受伤的感觉）与损伤（或实际受害）并不是一回事。受痛与受损并不是一回事。我真的感到很困惑，雷切尔。
What could possibly explain why he had such little pain? It is so baffling, and here's the answer. It's only baffling until we really understand the true science of pain, and then it makes perfect sense. Here's what happened. We've established that pain is the body's danger alarm, and we've established that the brain is our body's danger alarm. detector. So his brain, similar to the first construction worker, his brain also used all available
究竟是什么原因能解释他为什么几乎感觉不到疼痛？这太令人费解了，答案是这样的。这只有在我们真正理解了疼痛的真正科学之后才不再费解，那时一切就都说得通了。事情是这样的。我们已经确立了疼痛是身体的危险警报，我们也确立了大脑是我们身体的危险探测器。因此，他的大脑，类似于第一位建筑工人，他的大脑也利用了所有可用的
data to decide whether or not to make pain and how much. So his brain also used knowledge of his dangerous work environment, memories of past pain experiences, and visual data. But because he saw that nail shoot across the room and bury in the wall across from him, His brain was under the mistaken impression that the construction worker's body was safe. Credible evidence of danger will amplify the pain alarm. Credible evidence of safety will lower the pain alarm. So because his brain perceived that he was safe, the pain alarm did not sound. The biomedical model of pain holds that if something hurts,
数据来决定是否制造疼痛以及制造多少疼痛。所以他的大脑也利用了他对危险工作环境的认知、过去疼痛体验的记忆以及视觉数据。但因为他看到那根钉子射过房间并埋入对面的墙里，他的大脑产生了错误的印象，认为这位建筑工人的身体是安全的。关于危险的可信证据会放大疼痛警报。关于安全的可信证据会降低疼痛警报。因此，由于他的大脑感知到他是安全的，疼痛警报就没有拉响。生物医学疼痛模型认为，如果有地方痛，
there must be something wrong in the body that needs to be fixed. Sometimes that model does hold up, but as we've heard, it often falls short. When we come back, how pain really works in the body and the mind. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Pain is perhaps the most common of human experiences. We all think we understand it. You stub your toe, you feel pain.
身体里一定有什么地方出了问题需要修复。有时这种模型确实成立，但正如我们所听到的那样，它往往力不从心。稍后回来，我们将探讨疼痛在身体和大脑中是如何真正运作的。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。疼痛或许是人类最普遍的体验。我们都以为自己理解它。你踢到了脚趾，就会感到疼痛。
You accidentally scald yourself in the kitchen, and you feel the body. burn. It seems straightforward. But this intuitive model of pain turns out to be incomplete. Rachel Zoffness is a pain psychologist at the University of California, San Francisco School of Medicine. Rachel, contrary to the way we usually think about pain, you say that pain is constructed by the brain, not located in the body part that is hurting. Unpacked this idea for me, you're saying the brain is not merely perceiving pain, but it's actually constructing it? You got it. So it's very easy to believe that pain lives exclusively in the body part that hurts, right? So if you have a bad back or you have an aching knee, it's easy to believe that that pain is being constructed exclusively
你不小心在厨房里烫伤了自己，就会感到身体在燃烧。这看起来很简单。但这种关于疼痛的直观模型结果并不完整。雷切尔·佐夫尼斯是加利福尼亚大学旧金山分校医学院的疼痛心理学家。雷切尔，与我们通常认为的疼痛方式相反，你说疼痛是由大脑构建的，而不是位于正在疼痛的身体部位。请为我剖析这个观点，你是说大脑不仅仅是在感知疼痛，而实际上是在构建疼痛？完全正确。所以人们很容易认为疼痛完全存在于受伤的身体部位中，对吧？因此，如果你的背部不好或者膝盖酸痛，你很容易认为这种疼痛完全是由
by your back or your knee. But neuroscience tells us that is not true. Pain, is ultimately constructed by the brain. And one of the reasons we know this is because of a condition called phantom limb pain. And phantom limb pain occurs when someone loses a limb and arm or a leg, and they continue to have terrible pain in the missing body part. Now, if you can have terrible leg pain in a leg that is no longer attached to your body, that tells us pretty definitive. that pain must be constructed somewhere else, and we now know that somewhere else is the brain. So one of the animating ideas here, Rachel,
你的背部或膝盖构建出来的。但神经科学告诉我们，事实并非如此。疼痛最终是由大脑构建的。我们知道这一点的原因之一，是因为有一种叫做“幻肢痛”的病症。幻肢痛发生在当某人失去四肢（手臂或腿）时，他们仍然会感到缺失的身体部位传来剧烈的疼痛。现在，如果一个已经不再连接在你身体上的腿能够产生剧烈的腿痛，这就相当明确地告诉我们，
is something that we have discussed previously on Hidden Brain. The brain was designed by evolution to help us survive, and survival involves understanding what happened to us in the past, but even more, survival is really about deciding what to do next. And you're arguing that pain, like many other signals that the brain gives us, is really about future action rather than merely an accounting of past events. That's right. So pain's job is to protect us. There are people who do not feel very much pain and they don't live very long. The problem is there's a very big difference between acute pain,
疼痛一定是在其他地方构建的，而我们现在知道，那个其他地方就是大脑。所以，雷切尔，这里的核心理念之一，是我们之前在《隐藏的大脑》中讨论过的内容。大脑是通过进化设计来帮助我们生存的，而生存不仅涉及理解过去发生了什么，更重要的是，生存实际上是关于决定下一步该做什么。而你认为，疼痛就像大脑给我们的许多其他信号一样，实际上是关于未来的行动，而不仅仅是对过去事件的清算。没错。所以疼痛的工作是保护我们。有些人感受不到太多疼痛，他们也活不了多久。问题在于，急性疼痛（指三个月或更短时间）与慢性疼痛（指三个月或更长时间）之间存在着巨大的差异。它们的生物学设计不同，在大脑和神经系统中的运作方式不同，治疗方法也不同。而问题在于，我们正面临着一场慢性疼痛流行病。全球目前有1.9亿人正饱受慢性疼痛的折磨，仅在美国就有1亿人。正因为很少有人理解疼痛，我们不仅继续误解它，而且还在不当地治疗它。你刚才谈到了这种被称为幻肢痛的现象，而这个概念通过你的一个病人得到了生动的展示，那是一个你称之为马特奥（Mateo）的年轻男孩。雷切尔，你能描述一下你最初是如何认识他的吗？是的，马特奥是由一位外科医生转诊给我的，他给我打了个电话，向我讲述了一个当时正在他诊所里的病人，无论使用多少止痛药都无法降低疼痛的音量。
which is three months or fewer, and chronic pain, which is three months or longer. They are designed differently, they work differently in the brain and nervous system, and they are treated differently. And the problem is that we have a chronic pain epidemic. We have 1.9 billion people around the globe currently living with chronic pain, 100 million in the U.S. alone. And because very few people understand pain, we continue to not just misunderstand it, but also to mistreat it. You talked a second ago about this phenomenon called Phantom Pain, and this idea was vividly demonstrated by a patient of yours, a young man whom you called Mateo. Can you describe how you first met him, Rachel? Yes, Mateo was sent to me by a surgeon who called me on the phone, and he told me about a patient who was currently in his office, and no amount of pain medication was working to lower pain volume.
他说：“我需要你的帮助。你能看看这个孩子吗？”我很快了解到马特奥只有12岁，他在父母的车库里发现了一个烟花，他非常兴奋，像个12岁的孩子一样，他邀请朋友们去公园，这样他们就可以点燃烟花，所有人都能体验到烟花的快乐。
and he said, I need your help. Will you see this child? And I learned very quickly that Mateo was 12 years old, and he had found a firework in his parents' garage, and he was very excited, and like a 12-year-old would, he invited his friends to the park so they could detonate the firework, and they could all experience the joy of fireworks.
我确信听众们听到这里都会感到不寒而栗，因为他们知道接下来会发生什么。但是，你知道，马特奥后来告诉我的是，他说：“你知道，在动画片里，烟花总是连着一条非常长的引信。所以时间很充裕。你点燃引信。然后，你知道，歪心狼（Wile E. Coyote）或走鹃（Road Runner）有时间在它爆炸前跑开。”他以为这里也会发生同样的事情。但事实并非如此。所以他把这个烟花带到了公园。他和朋友们在一起。可以想象他们都在兴奋地围观。雷切尔，接下来发生了什么？他们围成一个圈，马特奥手里拿着烟花，他们点燃了引信。
And I'm sure the audience is cringing because they know what's coming, But, you know, what he told me later, Matteo, was he said, you know, in the cartoons, there's always a really long fuse attached to the firework. And so there's time. You light the fuse. And then, you know, Wiley Coyote or the Roadwiner, they have time to run away before it detonates. And that's what he assumed would happen here too. But that's not what happened. So he takes this firework out into the park. He's with his friends. Presumably they're all standing excitedly around. What happens next, Rachel? They're standing in a circle and Mateo was holding the firework in his hands and they light the fuse.
然而引信并没有花很长时间才爆炸，反而立刻就爆炸了。它烧焦了他脸上的皮肤，在他的耳膜上炸出一个洞，烧伤了他的角膜。它还炸掉了他的左手。所以这是一个非常糟糕的事故，雷切尔。马特奥一定被紧急送往了医院。是的，他被紧急送往医院。医生为了救他的命，不得不从肘部以下进行截肢，但他们确实救了他的命。
And instead of taking a long time to detonate, instead it exploded right away. And it seared the skin on his face. It blew a hole in his eardrum. It burned his cornea. And it also took off his left hand. So this is a really terrible accident, Rachel. Mateo must have been rushed to the hospital. Yeah, he was rushed to the hospital. The doctors had to amputate below the elbow to save him, but they did save him.
他们给我打电话的原因是，马特奥报告说，那个被截肢的手臂和手传来了剧烈的疼痛。所以他的手已经不再连接在身体上了，但他却经历着那只已经被切除的左手在抽筋和痉挛。这其实并不罕见，多达80%经历过幻肢的人都会经历幻肢痛。所以我想我们有些人听到幻肢痛时，会想象说，以前通往马特奥手部的神经现在在肘部被切断了，它们正在向他的大脑发送信号，表明他的手仍然在痛。你对幻肢痛提出了一个更复杂的观点，这与大脑中关于身体的地图有更大的关系？完全正确。所以，经历过创伤性损伤或
And the reason they called me was because Mateo was reporting terrible pain in the arm and the hand that they had amputated. So his hand was no longer attached to his body, but he was experiencing that left hand that had been removed, cramping and spasming. And that's not actually very unusual, up to 80% of people who have a phantom. limb experience phantom pain. So I think with some of us hear about phantom pain, we imagine that, you know, the nerves that would previously have gone out to Mateo's hand are now, you know, cut off at his elbow, and they are signaling to his brain that his hand is still hurting. You're presenting a more complicated view of phantom pain, and that has more to do with the map that the brain has of the body? That's right. So people who have had a traumatic injury or have
截肢的人可能会有残端痛。残端痛听名知义，就是由受伤部位产生的疼痛。这与我们这里讨论的疼痛是不同的一种。幻肢痛是马特奥所经历的那种情况，他的手已经被切除，已经没有手了。但存在于他大脑中的身体地图尚未用这些信息进行更新。因此，大脑中存在一张身体地图，它被称为“皮质侏儒”（homunculus）。皮质侏儒是人体的一张感觉运动地图。所以如果我现在对你说，尚卡尔，去感受一下你的左脚，看看你能不能在鞋子里感觉到它，感觉到袜子贴着皮肤，感觉到脚踩在地面上。你可以做到这一点。而你之所以能做到这一点，部分原因在于
had a limb amputated can have stump pain. And stump pain is what it sounds like. It's pain that's being generated by the injury site. And that is a different kind of pain than what we're talking about here. Phantom pain is when what Mateo was experiencing, where his hand had been removed, there was no hand left. But the map of his body that lived in his brain hadn't yet updated with that information. So there's a map of the body that lives in the brain, and it is called the homunculus. And the homunculus is a sensory motor map of the human body. So if I say to you right now, Shunker, sense into your left foot and see if you can feel it in your shoe and feel the sock on your skin and feel your foot on the floor. You can do that. And you can do that in part because of the
存在于你大脑中的皮质侏儒，它一直在为你提供关于整个身体的数据。当你遭遇不幸、经历创伤失去四肢时，大脑中的地图更新可能需要一些时间。因为如果没有像计算机那样进行更新，大脑就会产生错觉，认为那个身体部位仍然处于危险之中，并不断产生危险信号来引起你的注意。我想知道这种疼痛是如何影响这个小男孩的雷切尔。当你见到他时，他不仅在身体上痛苦，而且在心理上也备受煎熬。完全正确。我第一次见到马特奥时，他穿着一件过大的运动衫来掩盖他缺失的手臂。他缩在沙发里，好像想消失一样。他和父亲一起走进了我的办公室。他的父亲描述了他的儿子是如何彻底改变的。他变得退缩。他被社会孤立了。他不上学了。他几乎不吃东西。而且他和父母睡在一张床上。我了解到他还为发生的事情感到内疚，并在想他对自己和朋友造成的伤害，他是否应该为此感到内疚。他感觉糟透了。他觉得整场事故都是他的错，爆炸中还有其他孩子也受了伤。
homunculus that lives in your brain that's giving you data about your entire body. And when you tragically and traumatically lose a limb, it can take some time for the map in your brain to update. Because without this updating like a computer, the brain is under the impression that that body part is still in danger and it's producing danger messages to get your attention. I'm wondering how this pain affected this little boy, Rachel. When you saw him, he wasn't just in pain, but he was in psychological distress. That's absolutely right. When I first met Mateo, he was wearing an oversized sweatshirt to hide his missing arm. And he was shrunken into the couch as if he wanted to disappear. And he came to my office with his father. And his father described how his son had completely changed. He had withdrawn. He was socially isolated. He was not going to school. He was barely eating. And he was sleeping in bed with his parents. I understand that he also felt guilty about what happened and wondering whether the harm that he had done to himself and to his friends, whether he should be feeling guilty about it. He felt terrible. He felt like the entire accident was his fault and some other children had also gotten hurt during the explosion.
他觉得，是的，他感到极其内疚。疼痛的现实与我们对疼痛的传统认知相悖的另一个方面是，围绕疼痛的情境可以改变我们对它的体验。雷切尔，这是怎么回事？绝对是的。所以我们讨论过大脑如何成为我们身体的危险探测器，以及它是如何利用所有可用信息来决定是否制造疼痛以及制造多少疼痛的。
He felt like, yeah, he felt extremely guilty. Another way that the reality of pain departs from what we've conventionally believed about pain is that the context around pain. can change our experience of it. How is this the case, Rachel? Absolutely. So we talked about how our brain is our body's danger detector and how it uses all available information to decide whether or not to make pain and how much.
在我们大脑在任何给定时刻都在使用的因素中，就包括情境。我所说的情境是什么意思？情境意味着在任何给定时刻，在我们周围和我们体内发生的一切。我的意思是我们在哪里、和谁在一起、我们的感受如何，甚至是过去的记忆。这就是为什么如果你在被公司解雇的那天踢到脚趾，那感觉会完全不同于你在海滩上和
And among the things that our brain is using in any given moment is context. What do I mean by context? Context means everything happening around us and inside of us. in any given moment. And by that I mean where we are, who we're with, how we're feeling, even our past memories. And that's why if you stub your toe on the day you get fired from work, it is going to feel completely different than that exact same injury when you're at the beach with
朋友们在一起时遭受完全相同的伤害。这也是为什么，如果你是一个对刺激的性爱感兴趣的人，如果你和一个你信任并爱着的伴侣在一起，你被拍打、扇耳光和咬伤，那感觉会完全不同于你在遭遇抢劫时受到完全相同的伤害。当大脑决定是否制造疼痛以及制造多少疼痛时，情境对大脑来说始终至关重要。你知道，我记得小时候，我们有一个我很喜欢的家庭医生，每当我感到疼痛时，只要在这个医生身边，我的疼痛似乎就会神奇地消失。从某种程度上说，这就是你在这里谈论的，对吧？绝对是的。产生疼痛的情境是如此重要。这就是为什么用屏幕分散孩子的注意力会降低疼痛警报。这也是为什么去看一个我们
friends. And it's also why, if you're someone who is interested in spicy sex, if you're with a partner that you trust and love, and you get spanked and smacked and bitten, it will feel completely different than those exact same injuries when you are getting mugged. Context always matters to the brain when it's deciding whether or not to make pain and how much. You know, I remember as a small kid, we had a family doctor whom I really liked, and whenever I was in pain, just being in the presence of this doctor would magically make my pain seem to go away. In some ways, that's what you're talking. talking about here, isn't it? Absolutely. The context in which pain is delivered matters so much. It's why things like distracting a child with screens will lower the pain alarm. It's why going to a doctor that we
信任和喜欢的医生会改变疼痛体验。我的意思是，我们中的有些人，包括我在内，都有过这种令人发疯的经历：某个身体部位疼痛，比如你的牙齿或膝盖，你去了信得过的医生诊所，当你坐在候诊室里时，疼痛似乎就消失了，对吧？我的意思是，从某种程度上说这很让人抓狂，因为它只是在提醒我们，大脑在生命中的每一个瞬间都在使用所有可用的数据。慢性疼痛患者深知这一点，因为慢性疼痛患者会告诉我，他们的疼痛会在一个小时、一天、一个月的时间里发生变化。那是因为所有这些因素总是在共同作用，从而改变疼痛体验。现在，我想有些人听到这段
trust and like will change the pain experience. I mean, some of us, including me, have had this maddening experience wherein, you know, some body part hurts, your tooth or your knee, and you go to the trusted doctor's office and while you're sitting in the waiting room, the pain seems to disappear, right? I mean, it's maddening in a way because it's just this reminder that the brain is always using all available data in every single moment of our lives. And people with chronic pain know that because people with chronic pain will tell me that their pain will change over the course of an hour, a day, a month. And that's because all of these factors are always coming together to change the pain experience. Now, I think some people might hear this
对话可能会说，好吧，来自你脚踝神经末梢的疼痛信号，那是真正的疼痛。而在内心深处产生的疼痛信号，你知道，只是在你的脑子里。为什么这是思考疼痛的错误方式，雷切尔？人们会这样想是很自然的，这完全合乎情理。所以我想一劳永逸地澄清这一点。大脑中产生情绪的部位也会产生疼痛，比如我们的边缘系统、我们的杏仁核。这些都是疼痛机制的关键部分。而我们对疼痛的实际了解是，来自身体的100%的感觉信息在我们称之为疼痛的事物之前，都要经过大脑情绪机制的过滤。
conversation and say, okay, the pain signals that are coming from the nerve endings in your ankle, that is real pain. The pain signals that are being created within the mind are, you know, just in your head. Why is this the wrong way to think about pain, Rachel? Of course people would think that, and that makes good sense. So I want to clear this up once and for all. The parts of the brain that make emotions also make pain, our limbic system, our amygdala, Those are critical parts of the pain machinery. And what we actually know about pain is that 100% of the sensory messages from the body filter through our brain's emotion machinery before they become the thing we call pain.
疼痛绝不仅仅全在你的脑子里。疼痛绝不仅仅是纯粹的心理问题。100%的情况下，疼痛既是身体的，也是情绪的。疼痛不仅仅是来自身体单一信号，而是由大脑构建的一种体验，这一概念为治疗打开了无限可能。它暗示疼痛并非一成不变的，它可以受到我们思考方式和行为方式的影响。接下来即将播出。此外，在我们在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》中的配套单集中，我们将回到马特奥的故事，并介绍雷切尔用来帮助他重塑大脑的一项新颖技术。
Pain is never all in your head. Pain is never purely psychological. Pain is both physical and emotional 100% of the time. The notion that pain is not simply a single, signal from the body, but an experience constructed by the brain opens up a world of possibility for treatment. It implies that pain is not fixed, that it can be influenced by how we think and what we do. That's coming up next. Also, in our companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we return to Mateo's story and describe a novel technique that Rachel used to help him rewire
该故事还探讨了一个更大的问题，即我们如何利用大脑的……来管理疼痛。如果你已经是订阅者，该单集现在就可以在你的播客订阅源中收听。它的标题是《可塑的大脑，多变的大脑》（Plastic Brain, Changeable Brain）。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。
his brain. The story also explores the larger question of how we can use the plighton, and of the brain to manage pain. If you're already a subscriber, that episode is available to you right now in this podcast feed. It's titled Plastic Brain, Changeable Brain. If you're not yet a subscriber, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com 顺斜杠 hidden brain。你将立即访问我们所有仅限订阅者的内容，包括过去的单集。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。
If you're using an Apple device, please go to apple.com slash hidden brain. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这段对话是否唤起了你对疼痛的亲身经历？如果你有一个关于你是如何克服疼痛的个人故事，并愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，或者对本集有任何疑问或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。然后将该文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：Feedback at HiddenBrain.com。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Has this conversation evoked your own experience with pain? If you have a personal story about how you overcame pain that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us at Feedback at HiddenBrain.com.
主题行请用：pain。再重复一遍，邮箱是 feedback at hiddenbrain.org。雷切尔·佐夫尼斯是加利福尼亚大学旧金山分校医学院的心理学家。她是《告诉我哪里痛：疼痛的新科学与如何治愈》（Tell Me Where It Hurts: The New Science of Pain and How to Heal）一书的作者。雷切尔，你提出这样的观点：当我们思考疼痛时，我们不应该把它当作一个生物医学问题，而应该把它当作一个生物-心理-社会现象。你这个术语是什么意思？对。所以如果听众从今天的播客中记不住别的，我希望他们能记住这个词：生物-心理-社会。我想明确地说，这不是我个人的发明，不是我想出来的。神经科学已经知道65年了，疼痛
Use the subject line, pain. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Rachel Zoffness is a psychologist at the University of California, San Francisco School of Medicine. She's the author of Tell Me Where It Harts, the New Science of Pain and How to Heal. Rachel, you make the case that when we think about pain, we shouldn't think about it as a biomedical problem, but as a biopsycho-social, phenomenon. What do you mean by this term? Right. So if listeners remember nothing else from today's podcast, I hope they remember this word, biopsychosocial. And I want to say clearly, this is not my pet invention. I did not come up with this. Neuroscience has known for 65 years that pain is
绝不是纯粹的生物医学现象，不仅仅与骨骼和身体部位有关。疼痛比那更复杂、更美好、更微妙。所以如果你想象一个有三个重叠圆圈的韦恩图，顶部是“生物”，即导致疼痛的生物学因素；然后我们有心理因素；我们还有社会学因素，而疼痛就存在于让你成为你的所有因素的混乱中间地带。我想知道你能花一分钟谈谈每个圆圈里都有什么吗。是的。所以疼痛的生物领域是我们大家听得最多的一个。它是遗传学、组织损伤、系统功能障碍。它也是饮食、运动和睡眠。当涉及到疼痛体验时，这些都至关重要。但我想让我们
never a purely biomedical phenomenon, something to do just with bones and body parts. Pain is more complex and beautiful and nuanced than that. So if you imagine a Venn diagram with three overlapping circles, we have bio on the top, biological factors that contribute to pain, we've got psychological factors, and we've got sociological factors, and pain lives in the messy middle of all the things that make you, you. I'm wondering if you can spend a minute talking about what's in each of those circles, Rachel. Yes. So the biodomain of pain is the one we've all heard the most about. It's genetics and tissue damage, system dysfunction. It's also diet, exercise, and sleep. And those are all critically important when it comes to the experience of pain. But what I want us to
注意到的是，如果我们只关注疼痛的生物领域（这也是我们在西医中所做的），我们在字面上就漏掉了疼痛问题的三分之二。因此，在疼痛的心理领域，我们现在知道负面情绪（如压力、焦虑和抑郁情绪）会放大疼痛警报，而积极情绪（如喜悦、快乐、放松和感激）会降低大脑的疼痛警报。而在疼痛的社会化、社会学领域，我们有社会和环境因素。这包括社会经济地位、获得医疗服务的机会、种族和族裔、社会支持（或缺乏社会支持）以及我们的环境（包括虐待和创伤史）。因为事实证明，创伤不仅仅存在于
notice is that if we're only focusing on the biodomain of pain, which is what we do, we're do in Western medicine. We are literally missing two-thirds of the pain problem. So in the psych domain of pain, we now know negative emotions like stress, anxiety, and depressed mood will amplify the pain alarm, while positive emotions like joy and happiness and relaxation and gratitude will lower the brain's pain alarm. And in the socialization, sociological domain of pain, we have social and environmental factors. And that includes socioeconomic status, access to care, race and ethnicity, social support or lack thereof, and our environment, which includes history of abuse and trauma. Because trauma, it turns out, doesn't just live in the
大脑中，它也存在于身体中。创伤和慢性疼痛是最好的朋友。令我感到如此迷人和震惊的是，我们已经知道这门科学几十年了，但它还没有进入医学或治疗领域。所以，当试图对抗疼痛时，鉴于这种复杂的力相互作用，你认为直接解决情绪健康问题非常重要。
brain, it also lives in the body. And trauma and chronic pain, our best friends. And what's so fascinating and shocking to me is that we have known this science for many decades, but it hasn't yet found its way to medicine or treatment. So when it comes to trying to combat pain, given this complex interplay of forces, you say that it's important to address emotional health directly.
现在，对一个有背痛问题的人说要注意他们的焦虑或悲伤，这似乎很奇怪，但你提出的是，我们的情绪状态很大程度上塑造了我们所体验到的疼痛。没错，因为我们知道大脑中产生情绪的部位也会产生疼痛。我们拥有的每一种情绪都会在人体内引发一系列生理事件，从而影响我们的所有系统。例如，当我们感到压力或焦虑时，我们可能会心跳加速，也许我们的口
Now, it can seem odd to tell someone who has a back problem to pay attention to their anxiety or their sadness, but you're making the case that our emotional states very much shape the pain that we experience. That's right, because we know that the parts of the brain that make emotions also make pain. Every emotion we have triggers a physiological cascade of events in the human body that affects all of our systems. So, for example, when we get stressed or anxious, we might have a racing heart, maybe our mouth
干，手心会出汗。对我很疯狂的是，在谈到身体健康时，我们却不谈论我们的情绪健康。情绪深刻且不断地改变着疼痛体验。我们都知道这一点。我们已经看到我们的身体在压力和苦难时期感觉有多糟糕。你还建议那些饱受慢性疼痛折磨的人应该寻找加强社交联系的方法。这会对他们的疼痛有什么帮助呢？对。你可以对一个人施加的最糟糕的惩罚之一就是单独监禁。你可以对我们做的最糟糕的事情之一就是将我们与他人隔绝，这说明了人类的什么本质？人类进化为群居动物。事实上，社交行为对我们的生存至关重要，以至于我们的大脑进化出了一种机制，来奖励我们参与其中。
get dry, our palms will get sweaty. What's crazy to me is that we don't talk about our emotional health when it comes to physical health. Emotions profoundly and constantly change the pain experience. And we all know that. We've seen how our bodies feel worse during times of stress and duress. You also recommend that people who suffer from chronic pain should find ways to strengthen their social connections. How would this help them with their pain? Right. One of the worst punishments you can give a human being is solitary confinement. What does it say about human beings that one of the worst things you can do to us is isolate us from others? Humans evolved to be social. In fact, social behavior is so critical for our survival that our brains evolved a mechanism to reward us for engaging in it.
在其他人的陪伴下，我们的大脑会产生让人感觉良好的脑内化学物质，比如多巴胺（当然，它关乎动机和奖励）、血清素（能提升我们的情绪）以及内源性阿片类药物。当我们和别人在一起时，我们在情感上和身体上都会感觉更好。而当我们被孤立时，我们在身体和情感上都会感觉更糟。还有另一个数据点我想与大家分享。人们对老年人进行了大量的研究。在那些孤独、孤立和独居的人群中，发病率和死亡率更高——也就是患病和死亡的比率更高。
In the presence of other people, our brains produce feel-good brain chemicals like dopamine, which of course is motivation and reward, serotonin, which boosts our mood, and endogenous opioids. When we are with other people, we feel better both emotionally and physically. And when we are isolated, we feel worse physically and emotionally. And there's one more data point I want to share with you. There's been a lot of research conducted on the elderly. And among those who are lonely and isolated and alone, rates of morbidity and mortality are higher rates of disease and death.
因此，这意味着如果你很健康，但你感到孤独、孤立且独居，你更有可能生病。如果你已经生病了，你更有可能病情加重。而且你也更有可能死亡。这背后的原因有很多，但我发现其中一个非常引人注目的原因是，当我们长期感到孤独和孤立时，我们的身体会产生高水平的皮质醇，
And so what that means is if you are healthy and you're lonely and isolated and alone, you are more likely to get sick. If you are already sick, you are more likely to get sicker. and you are also more likely to die. And there's a number of reasons for this, but one of the reasons that I find so compelling is that when we are chronically lonely and isolated, our bodies produce high levels of cortisol,
这是一种压力荷尔蒙，随着时间的推移会抑制我们的免疫系统，这当然会影响发病率和死亡率，也会影响疼痛。社交行为绝对且深刻地改变了我们的人体，它对我们感受到的疼痛有着巨大的影响。在与正在应对疼痛的患者合作时，你还帮助他们改善睡眠、饮食和日常节律。请稍微谈谈这样做的价值，雷切尔。没错。就像做布朗尼蛋糕有食谱一样，疼痛也总是有个食谱。我们讨论过疼痛是生物-心理-社会的。因此，在高疼痛日的这份食谱中，有许多生物、心理和社会的成分在促成
which is a stress hormone that over time suppresses our immune system, which of course affects morbidity and mortality and also pain. Social behavior absolutely and profoundly changes our human body, and it has a huge impact on the pain we feel. You also, in working with patients who are dealing with pain, you help them improve their sleep and diet and daily rhythms. Talk a little bit about the value of doing this, Rachel. That's right. So just as there's a recipe for brownies, there is always a recipe for pain. and we talked about how pain is biopsychosocial. So in this recipe for a high pain day, there are a number of biological, psychological, and sociological ingredients that are going into
疼痛的放大。所以我要给你我的高疼痛食谱。例如，如果我坐着盯着电脑太多个小时，睡眠质量很差，饮食很糟糕，而且没有留出时间让身体活动和锻炼，并且被社会孤立。我知道，再加上其他一些成分，这就将构成我喜欢称之为“高疼痛食谱”的东西。现在，与我的患者一起构建疼痛食谱的非常酷的一点是，一旦我能够帮助他们绘制出高疼痛食谱，我们就能够构建低疼痛食谱。而低疼痛食谱通常正好相反。我刚才提到了睡眠质量差。睡眠质量差对我来说是高疼痛的预测指标。所以我知道，如果我想改变我的疼痛食谱，
pain amplification. So I'm going to give you my high pain recipe. For example, if I'm sitting and staring at the computer for too many hours and I've had a poor night's sleep and I'm eating a crap diet, and I'm not protecting time to move my body and exercise, and I'm socially isolated. I know that combined with some other ingredients, that is going to construct what I like to call a high pain recipe. Now, the really cool thing about constructing pain recipes with my patients is that as soon as I'm able to help them map out a high pain recipe, we are then able to construct a low pain recipe. And a low pain recipe is often just the opposite. So I mentioned poor sleep. Poor sleep for me is a predictor of high pain. So I know that if I want to change my pain recipe,
我需要开始实施睡眠卫生方案。例如，对我自己而言，我需要设定就寝时间和醒来时间。我知道我需要在睡前停止疯狂刷手机，在准备上床睡觉前把手机收起来几个小时。我知道如果我睡不着觉，开始感到焦虑和烦躁，我需要离开床去别的地方，而不是躺在床上感到烦躁和焦虑。因此，高疼痛食谱中的每一种成分，都有一个与之相对应的成分，我们有力量和自主权去改变它，从而创造出我所说的“低疼痛食谱”。
I need to start implementing a sleep hygiene protocol. For example, for myself, I know that I need to set a sleep time and awake time. I know that I need to stop doom scrolling before bed. and put my phone away a couple of hours before getting into bed. I know that if I can't sleep and I'm getting anxious and restless, I need to get out of bed and go somewhere else and not lay in bed feeling restless and anxious. So for every ingredient in the high pain recipe, there is a matching corresponding ingredient that we have the power and agency to change to create what I call a low pain recipe.
每个人都有一份这样的食谱，而且它们对我们来说是独一无二的。因此，每个人都有能力做到的一点，就是审视他们的高疼痛食谱中的成分，并找到一些有助于我们实现低疼痛食谱的策略。雷切尔，有些慢性疼痛患者经历过的一种情况是，脑海中基本上有一个声音对他们说：“我坏掉了，我永远不会好起来，我的身体讨厌我，我是朋友和家人的负担。”
And everyone has one and they're unique to us. So that's something that everyone has the power to do is to look at the ingredients in their high pain recipe and find some strategies that help us achieve a low pain recipe. One thing that some people with chronic pain experience, Rachel, is a voice that basically says to them, I'm broken, I'll never get better, my body hates me, I'm a burden on my friends and family. talk about the role that this voice plays in our experience of pain? Yeah, so that's quite normal and expected when we have pain. And I call this voice pain voice. And the reason I name it pain voice is because I think it's so important for us to recognize that it's a voice of negative predictions, worries and fears and worst-case scenarios
请谈谈这个声音在我们疼痛体验中扮演的角色？是的，当我们经历疼痛时，这是非常正常和意料之中的事。我把这个声音叫做“疼痛之声”。我给它起这个名字的原因是，我认为对我们来说，认识到它是消极预测、担忧、恐惧以及最坏情况的声音，是极其重要的。
that commonly accompanies pain, but it isn't us. That's just pain voice. and its job is to protect you. And to protect you, sometimes it gives us these negative predictions. But here's the thing about thoughts. Thoughts don't just live in the space between our ears. Thoughts are physiological, neurological events that trigger a cascade of events in the human body that affects all of our systems, our neurotransmitters, our hormones, our immune system, circulation, digestion, our musculoskeletal system, like all the way down the line. So every thought we
通常伴随着疼痛，但那并不是我们。那只是痛苦之声，它的工作是保护你。为了保护你，有时它会给我们这些负面预测。但关于想法，情况是这样的：想法不仅仅存在于我们两耳之间的空间里。想法是生理和神经事件，会在人体内引发一连串事件，影响我们所有的系统、神经递质、荷尔蒙、免疫系统、血液循环、消化系统、肌肉骨骼系统，可以说是全方位的。所以我们所想的每一个
think has a profound impact on the human body, which of course affects the pain we feel. And neuroscience has shown us that negative thoughts actually amplify pain because of this neurobiological cascade I just mentioned. And neuroscience also tells us that the opposite is also true. In fact, 70% of studies on pain and optimism show a real connection between hopeful thoughts and reductions in pain intensity, pain frequency, and even disability. I'm wondering if people have this pain voice inside their heads. How do you recommend they change it? One of my favorite strategies for dealing with pain voice is this strategy called using detective questions. And by that I mean, pain voice likes to speak in hyperbole and negative predictions that actually aren't rooted in reality.
想法都对人体有着深远的影响，这当然会影响我们感受到的疼痛。神经科学已经向我们表明，由于我刚才提到的这种神经生物学连锁反应，负面想法实际上会放大疼痛。神经科学还告诉我们，反之亦然。事实上，70%关于疼痛和乐观主义的研究表明，充满希望的想法与疼痛强度、疼痛频率甚至残疾程度的降低之间存在着真实的联系。我想知道如果人们脑海里有这种痛苦之声，你建议他们如何改变它？我处理痛苦之声最喜欢的一个策略之一，就是使用侦探式提问的策略。我的意思是，痛苦之声喜欢用夸张的修辞和负面预测来发言，而这些实际上并没有植根于现实。
And the only way sometimes for us to see for sure that the thought is just a thought and not a fact is to test its veracity. And by testing its veracity, I mean I'm going to sit down and ask those thoughts some questions. And I call these detective questions because I want to investigate. whether the thought is true or whether it's a trap. Because chances are high, if it's pain voice, it's trapping me into being scared and immobilized in order to protect me. Again, pain voice isn't mean. It's just trying to protect you and keep you immobilized until you get the help you need. So one detective question that I like to recommend is, is this thought a fact?
有时我们确信某个想法只是想法而不是事实的唯一方法，就是检验其真实性。通过检验其真实性，我的意思是，我要坐下来对这些想法提出一些问题。我把这些叫做侦探式提问，因为我想调查这个想法到底是真是假，还是一个陷阱。因为如果它是痛苦之声，它极有可能是为了保护我而把我引入恐惧和行动受限的陷阱中。再次说明，痛苦之声并不是恶意的。它只是试图保护你并让你保持不动，直到你获得需要的帮助。所以我喜欢推荐的一个侦探式问题是：这个想法是事实吗？
And by fact, I mean unquestionably, undeniably, absolutely true. So the thought you offered, I'm broken, I'll never get better. Is that a fact? And I think anyone, once they're critically looking at that thought, can tell you that is not a fact. It is not a fact that I will never, ever get better. That can't possibly be true because I don't have the ability to predict the future. A reminder that if you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone.
所谓事实，我的意思是毫无疑问的、不可否认的、绝对真实的事实。所以你提出的那个想法：“我崩溃了，我永远不会好起来了。”这真的是个事实吗？我想任何人只要批判性地审视一下这个想法，就能告诉你这不是事实。说我永远、永远不会好起来，这不是事实。这绝对不可能为真，因为我没有预测未来的能力。提醒大家，如果你有一个个人故事愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，或者对本集节目有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。
Two or three minutes is plenty. We are especially interested in ways that you have learned to manage your pain and techniques that you found helpful that could be helpful to others. Email the recording to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. use the subject line, pain. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. As we've seen, the mind plays an important role in the treatment of pain. This was brought home very clearly to Rachel when one of her patients named Kai was unwittingly enrolled in an experiment by his own sister.
两到三分钟就足够了。我们特别感兴趣的是你学会管理疼痛的方法，以及你觉得有帮助且也能帮助到别人的技巧。请将录音发送到我们的电子邮箱：Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请填写：pain。再次强调，邮箱是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。正如我们所看到的，大脑在疼痛治疗中扮演着重要角色。当雷切尔的一位名叫凯的患者无意中被他自己的姐姐纳入了一项实验时，这一点被非常清楚地展现了出来。
Kai was a patient I had, I believe he was in his 40s, and he was wheeled into my office by his sister, Ico. He had a condition called Fabri disease. and he wasn't able to go to work. And his pain was so terrible that he couldn't wear shoes or even cut his toenails. So he had these extremely long toenails that looked like talons. And it really just stood out to me because he wasn't even able to touch his own feet. As I got to know, Iko and Kai, we talked about the science of pain.
凯是我的一位患者，我记得他四十多岁，是被他的姐姐爱子用轮椅推进我办公室的。他患有一种叫做法布雷病的疾病。他无法去上班。他的疼痛太剧烈了，以至于他不能穿鞋，甚至不能剪脚趾甲。所以他的脚趾甲长得极长，看起来像鹰爪。这真的让我印象深刻，因为他甚至无法触碰自己的双脚。在了解爱子和凯的过程中，我们讨论了疼痛科学。
We talked about the role of the brain. We started putting together his pain recipe. And as we were on this journey together, Kai was prescribed. by a trusted provider, CBD gummies. And so Kai went home and his sister gave him one of these CBD gummies. And if I remember correctly, it was cherry flavored and bear shaped. And he took the CBD gummy and it made him very sleepy and he wheeled himself into the living room and he lay down on the couch and he fell asleep. And when he woke up, his pain was gone. And he couldn't believe it. And he stood up and he even touched his feet and he put on his shoes and he called his sister into the room.
我们讨论了大脑的作用。我们开始拼凑他的疼痛处方。正当我们一起经历这段旅程时，凯被一位值得信赖的医疗提供者开具了 CBD 软糖。于是凯回家了，他的姐姐给了他一颗这种 CBD 软糖。如果我没记错的话，它是樱桃味的，熊形状的。他吃了 CBD 软糖，这让他非常困倦，他自己摇着轮椅进客厅，躺在沙发上睡着了。当他醒来时，他的疼痛消失了。他简直不敢相信。他站起来甚至摸了自己的脚，穿上了鞋，把姐姐叫进了房间。
They were both astonished. And when he woke up the next morning, the pain had returned. So the next day they went through the same routine. She gave him a CBD gummy. He wheeled himself into the living room, lay down on the couch, fell asleep. When he woke up, the pain was gone. Now, his sister wondered if maybe there was more to it than just that. She wondered if his prediction and his expectations also had something to do with it. So she conducted an experiment without my knowledge. I did not know she was doing this, but she went to the store. She bought regular cherry gummy bears and she swapped out his CBD gummies for these regular cherry gummies. And the next day, Kai came in to get his medication. She handed him a regular cherry gummy bear. And here's what
他们都大吃一惊。当他第二天早上醒来时，疼痛复发了。所以第二天他们重复了同样的流程。她给了他一颗 CBD 软糖。他摇着轮椅进客厅，躺在沙发上，睡着了。醒来时，疼痛消失了。现在，他的姐姐想知道事情可能不仅仅如此。她想知道他的预测和期望是否也起到了一定作用。于是她在不知情的情况下进行了一项实验。我不知道她在这样做，但她去了商店。她买了一般的樱桃味小熊软糖，用这些普通的樱桃软糖替换了他的 CBD 软糖。第二天，凯来拿他的药物。她递给他一颗普通的樱桃味小熊软糖。以下是
happened. He got sleepy and tired. He wheeled himself into the living room. he lay down on the couch, he fell asleep, and when he woke up, his pain was gone. And Iko was astonished. And of course, Kai didn't even know that his gummies had been swapped out. And Iko did this every day for a week. She gave him a placebo gummy, Kai's pain disappeared, and the next day when the placebo effect wore off, she would give him a new regular cherry gummy bear. And after a week, she told me she felt so guilty that she told Kai what she had done and expected him to be enraged. But instead, he felt hopeful and happy and relieved because what it told him was that there was something happening with his pain that was more than just a medication and that there maybe were some things that he could do to change his pain beyond just the gummy bears. And of course, we talked earlier about the biopsychosocial.
发生的事情：他感到困倦和疲惫。他摇着轮椅进客厅，躺在沙发上，睡着了，醒来时疼痛消失了。爱子大吃一惊。当然，凯甚至不知道他的软糖被调包了。爱子连续一周每天都这么做。她给他一颗安慰剂软糖，凯的疼痛消失了，第二天当安慰剂效应消退时，她会给他一颗新的普通樱桃味小熊软糖。一周后，她告诉我她感到非常内疚，于是她把自己的所作所为告诉了凯，并预计凯会雷霆大怒。但相反，他感到充满希望、快乐和释然，因为这告诉他，关于他的疼痛，正在发生的事情不仅仅是药物本身，而且除了小熊软糖之外，也许还有一些事情是他自己可以做来改变疼痛的。当然，我们之前讨论过生物心理社会
model if your psychological prediction is, in fact, you are going to get better because you've taken a medication that's going to help you. It's not surprising that that's actually going to change where you end up on that Venn diagram, that biopsychosocial Venn diagram. That's exactly right, because thoughts and predictions trigger a biological cascade of events in the human body that affects systems throughout the human body, including our neurotransmitters, our hormones, our musculoskeletal system, and thoughts and predictions can actually physiologically lower the brain's pain alarm. You had a patient, a teenager whom you called Sam, who had experienced a lot of pain without a
模型，如果你的心理预测实际上是你将会好起来，因为你吃了一种能帮你康复的药物。那么，这最终会改变你在那个韦恩图（即生物心理社会韦恩图）上的位置，也就不足为奇了。完全正确，因为想法和预测会引发人体内的一连串生物学事件，影响全身各系统的运作，包括我们的神经递质、荷尔蒙、肌肉骨骼系统，而且想法和预测在生理上确实可以调低大脑的疼痛警报。你曾有一位患者，是一位你称之为萨姆的青少年，他经历了很多疼痛，但没有
clear diagnosis. He'd been to lots and lots of providers. He had started to withdraw from studies and from sports. When he came to you, Rachel, describe his affect and how you started to work with him. When I first met Sam, he was 17 years old. He had been in bed for four years. he had long unwashed hair, he was pasty and pale, and he was rocking himself back and forth on my couch with the pain. So he had been diagnosed with chronic migraine and diffuse amplified body pain of unknown etiology, meaning he had seen a bazillion doctor's, something like 14 of them, and he had been on 40 medications, but nothing had helped, and no one really understood why Sam was in so much pain. So by training, I've been studying pain neuroscience, pain biology, and pain psychology
明确的诊断。他去过非常非常多的医疗机构。他开始退出学业和运动。当你见到他时，雷切尔，请描述一下他的精神状态以及你是如何开始与他合作的。我第一次见到萨姆时，他17岁。他已经在床上躺了四年了。他留着长长的、没洗过的头发，面色苍白，在我的沙发上伴随着疼痛前后摇晃着身体。他被诊断出患有慢性偏头痛和病因不明的弥漫性放大性身体疼痛，这意味着他看过了无数的医生，大约有14个之多，他吃过40种药物，但没有什么管用，也没有人真正明白为什么萨姆会有这么剧烈的疼痛。从专业背景来看，我一直在研究疼痛神经科学、疼痛生物学和疼痛心理学
for 35 years, but I think of myself really as a pain detective, because it's my job to look at all of the biopsychosocial factors that are going into creating and amplifying the pain to see what I can do to help turn pain volume down. So as I conducted an assessment of Sam, I quickly learned that Sam had been living with crippling social anxiety and suicidality for many years without relief or adequate treatment. He was also sleeping poorly. He was up playing video games until four in the morning. He was on what I like to call a white food diet, which is not uncommon in America, where he was eating pizza, pasta, chips, and cereal, but he just didn't like fruits and vegetables. And so he wasn't, eating them. And what became clear to me was that if I wanted to help Sam, I needed to help him
35年了，但我认为自己实际上是一个疼痛侦探，因为我的工作是审视所有导致和放大疼痛的生物心理社会因素，看看我能做些什么来帮助调低疼痛音量。因此，在对萨姆进行评估时，我很快了解到，萨姆多年来一直生活在令人崩溃的社交焦虑和自杀倾向中，没有得到缓解或充分治疗。他睡眠也很差。他玩电子游戏一直玩到凌晨四点。他处于我喜欢称之为“白色食物饮食”的状态，这在美国并不罕见，他吃披萨、意面、薯片和麦片，但他就是不喜欢水果和蔬菜。所以他根本不吃它们。对我来说显而易见的是，如果我想帮助萨姆，我需要帮他
target all of the ingredients in his recipe. Medications alone just weren't going to cut it. And of course, they hadn't. So I met with Sam and his parents, and we introduced him to fruits and vegetables, one per meal. We put Sam on a sleep hygiene protocol to help him improve his sleep. And I put him also on a pacing protocol. And we said before that pacing for pain is much like pacing for a marathon. So what that meant for Sam, who had been bedbound for four years, and had been completely socially isolated and depressed and alone, was that week one, he got out of bed and he stood outside on the porch in the sun.
解决他“处方”中的所有成分。单靠药物是远远不够的。当然，事实也确实如此。于是我见到了萨姆和他的父母，我们向他介绍了水果和蔬菜，每餐一种。我们让萨姆遵循睡眠卫生方案来帮助他改善睡眠。我还让他遵循节奏调整方案。我们之前说过，疼痛的节奏调整非常类似于马拉松的节奏调整。所以对于已经卧床四年、完全社交隔离、抑郁且孤独的萨姆来说，这意味着第一周，他起床走到门廊外晒太阳。
That was step one of his pacing protocol. week two, he walked to the corner mailbox and he texted just one friend. Week three, he walked around the block and he invited a friend over to watch a movie. And you'll notice, you know, we're targeting sleep, we're targeting social behavior, we're targeting movement, we're targeting nutrition, we're targeting his mood and his physical health. All of the things we're targeting. And Sam also got a tutor and he started catching up in school. And here's what happened. As Sam's social and emotional and physical health started to improve, pain volume started to go down.
那是他节奏调整方案的第一步。第二周，他走到街角的邮箱，给一个朋友发了条短信。第三周，他绕着街区散步，并邀请一个朋友过来一起看电影。你会注意到，我们在关注睡眠，关注社交行为，关注运动，关注营养，关注他的情绪和身体健康。我们关注了所有这些方面。萨姆还请了家教，开始赶上学业。事情是这样的：随着萨姆的社交、情感和身体健康开始改善，疼痛的音量开始下降。
And Sam eventually went back to high school. This is my favorite detail of the story. When he went back to high school, he got asked to prom not by one girl but by two. and he said yes to both. And when he finally graduated high school, Sam walked on stage, and he told us all, you know, if you had told me four years ago, I'd be graduating high school, I never would have believed you. And, you know, he went off to college and he went off to work and has a job and has a life. And what's so critically important to me about this story is that Sam can be anyone of any age. And the critical detail here is that everyone has a pain recipe,
萨姆最终回到了高中。这是这个故事里我最喜欢的细节。当他回到高中时，他被邀请去参加毕业舞会，不是被一个女孩，而是被两个女孩邀请。两个他都答应了。当他最终高中毕业时，萨姆走上舞台，他对我们所有人说：“如果你四年前告诉我，我会高中毕业，我绝对不会相信的。”而且，你知道的，他去上大学，去工作，有了一份工作，也有了生活。这个故事对我很关键、很重要的意义在于，萨姆可以是任何年龄的任何人。这里的关键细节是，每个人都有一个疼痛处方，
and there are many ingredients in that pain recipe. And we have the power to change those ingredients, because ultimately, pain is a whole person problem that requires a whole person solution. Rachel Zoffness is a psychologist at the University of California, San Francisco School of Medicine. She's the author of Tell Me Where It Hurts, the new science of pain and how to heal.
那个疼痛处方里有很多成分。我们有力量改变这些成分，因为归根结底，疼痛是一个全人问题，需要一个全人的解决方案。雷切尔·佐夫尼斯是加利福尼亚大学旧金山分校医学院的心理学家。她是《告诉我哪里痛：疼痛的新科学及如何治愈》一书的作者。
Rachel, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. This has been a singular and wonderful experience. Thank you for having me. In our companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we return to the story of the little boy who experienced phantom pain after the lower part of his arm was amputated. Rachel describes a novel technique that she used to help Matteo rewire his brain. The story also explores the larger question of how we can need,
雷切尔，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。这是一次独特而美妙的体验。谢谢邀请我。在我们于《隐藏的大脑 Plus》播出的配套节目中，我们回到了那个在手臂下半截被截肢后经历幻肢痛的小男孩的故事。雷切尔描述了一种新颖的技术，她用它来帮助马特奥重塑大脑。该故事还探讨了一个更大的问题，即我们如何需要、
use the plasticity of the brain to manage pain. If you're already a subscriber, that episode is available to you right now in this podcast feed. It's titled Plastic Brain, Changeable Brain. If you're not yet a subscriber, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, please go to apple.com slash hidden brain. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes. Hidden Brain is produced. by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul,
利用大脑的可塑性来管理疼痛。如果你已经是订阅者，该集节目现在就可以在你的播客订阅源中收听。它的标题是《可塑的大脑，可变的大脑》（Plastic Brain, Changeable Brain）。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。你将立即访问我们所有的专属订阅内容，包括往期节目。《隐藏的大脑》由
Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you like this episode, please think of a friend who might like it
Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、
and share this episode with them. If they are new to Hidden Brain, they may also discover other episodes that are of interest. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you see. soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
克里斯滕·王、劳拉·克雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢这一集，请想想哪个朋友可能会喜欢，并把这一集分享给他们。如果他们是《隐藏的大脑》的新听众，他们可能也会发现其他感兴趣的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。